Beating of the drums echoes the beating of the drums, wenn man merkt, dass man den Text falsch angefangen hat. Also, wir haben heute nicht so viel Zeit, deswegen ganz kurz vorstellen, mein Name ist Stefan Dietz, das ist Flutimus. Wir haben nicht so viel Zeit, wir haben uns Flutimus weg, deswegen ganz kurz Podcast-Ufo, ich denke, die ganze Setting ist klar. Leute, Ken ist einer der erfolgreichsten Podcast auf Spotify. Okay, wir wir sind, wir wollen lustig sein. Profolofo. Meistens ist es eine Stunde lang, das schaffen wir heute nicht, weil Florian Tintin wecken muss. Es ist ein bisschen Druck in die Sache, ich finde es ein bisschen spannend. Energetisch muss es aufgeladen sein und ich bin gespannt, was Florian Tintin für lustige Sachen vorbereitet hat. Deine erste lustige Eindote, bitte schau. Okay, also erste lustige Eindote. Ich war jetzt im ICE unterwegs und es ist mir wieder aufgefallen, mein Gott, die Reservierungen sind aber auch immer manchmal auf. Oh nein, dann sitzt sie eben auf seinem Platz, was was macht man denn dann? Und dann ist die Frage, was macht man? Ja, und dann sage ich immer, mein Gott ist wieder nicht weg und dann denke ich mir, das war einfach furchtbar. Ne, ganz im Ernst, ich habe eine Powerbank. Jetzt kommt, wenn auf die Frage, hast du eine Anekdote, wenn dich eine Anekdote kommt, ich glaube, die ist meistens nicht so gut. Ja gut, wir werden sehen. Schön, dass du schon mal den Teppich so ausrollst. Weil der Teppich nicht gut ausgerollt ist. Weißt du, weil das muss organisch aus dem Gespräch entstehen. Das machen viele Podcasts, andere Podcasts falsch. Okay. Da muss ich kurz mal lehrend sein. Das machen die nicht richtig. Da schaust du ganz kurz, ja. Oh, jetzt hätte ich aber, jetzt hätte ich fast, wäre ich fast hämisch geworden. Breaker, Breaker, lieber Podcast-Community. Over. Ich sage Podcast, du sagst UFO. UFO. Nee, Moment. Das hast du. Warte, fang nochmal an. Du musst dran halten. Breaker. Nee, du darfst ja nicht den Aufdrücken. Hab ich nicht. Breaker, Breaker, Podcast Community, over. Was soll er? Ich sage Podcast, ihr seid Ufo, Podcast. Ufo, over. Podcast. Over. Over. Poffe, Ufats, over. Hier ist Stefan Tietze und Florian Tiewil miteinander fangen. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen technisch angeheiterten Folge Podcast. Wir sind in der Zeit gereist, 80 Jahre zurück. Es macht so Spaß, wir haben heute Walkie-Talkies gekauft und haben den ganzen Tag schon über Walkie-Talkies gesprochen. Wir haben schon den ganzen Code gelernt, Breaker, Breaker, Watch Your 20, damit die Polizei, falls sie auf uns reinhört, natürlich keine Ahnung hat, wo es geht. Wir haben herausgefunden, dass wenn man einen Polizeihelikopter in der Luft sieht, muss man Bear in the air sein. Genau, nur ein Bear ist ein Polizist und ein Polizeihubschrauber ist ein Bear in the air. Und Polizistin ist Miss Piggy. Warum müssen Polizistinnen einen extra Namen bekommen? Wahrscheinlich so, hey, siehst du die Miss Piggy dahinten an der Ecke? Pass auf, Breaker, Breaker, Over, On, Out. Das Over macht einen ein bisschen wahnsinnig. Und ich verstehe auch nicht genau den Sinn dahinter. Also na klar, Leute müssen verstehen, du hast den Satz beendet, aber im Normalgespräch hast du das Problem ja auch. Du weißt nicht, habe ich den Satz jetzt richtig beendet, oder? Na, ich glaube, im Normalgespräch können Leute gleichzeitig sprechen, wohingegen bei einer Radioübertragung kann immer nur einer sprechen, währenddessen kann der andere nicht sprechen. Das heißt, er muss auf das Over hören, bis er dann selber anfangen kann zu sprechen. Tr weiss man im normalen Gespräch genauso gut, wann ein Satz beendet ist.
Was ist ein Telegramm mit diesem Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Stopp UFO mit Stefan Stopp Titze?
Was soll das mit diesem Stopp?
Ja, auch eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, das ist ein Leerzeichen oder sowas.
Morsen ist auch so eine Frage. Morsen. Was genau hat man denn da gemorst?
Hat man auch andere Sachen, hat man auch Satzzeichen gemorst, ja, oder? Oder war das nur eine längere Pause? Kannst du mir kurz sagen, wie dieser Song heisst? Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, das ist der Imperial Martyrs-Dawars. So ungefähr stechen wir das vor. Oh, ja, stopp, Stover. Es macht ja auf jeden Fall großen Spaß. Meine Technik ist was Tolles. Wir haben heute beim... When Love Takes Over, Over. Das wäre lustig, wenn die den... Wie heißt dieser Song? Nee. Nee, dann müsste er sagen, Love Takes Over. Und dann Love Takes What, Over. Love Takes over, over. Genau. Ja, sucht euch den Lieblingsgag aus, wir präsentieren euch ein wildes Potpourri von verschiedenen Gags. Mit der Pointeins, Florentin Will für Albanien, mit der Stadt Nummer eins. Mit der Stadt Nummer zwei, Stefan Dietze für die Mongolei. Grosse RTL-Pointenrennen finde ich eigentlich auch nicht schlecht. So wie so ein Eurovision-Gag-Contest. Das wäre richtig geil, ey. Das wäre richtig cool. Es gab ja früher mal auch so eine Comedy-Casting-Show, wo Leute nicht gesungen haben, sondern Stand-Up-Comedy gemacht haben. Ich glaube, es war Star Search und da gab es auch andere Sachen. Domino Search! Da ist, wie hieß der nochmal? Ja, Ingo Oschmann. Ingo Oschmann, genau. Ey, der ist meinstigster Name der Welt. Ingo Oschmann. Aber Gags sind erst dann gut, wenn man sie auf T-Shirts schreiben kann. Ja. Und es ist genauso wie diese Alzheimer-Bulimie von Sinja Osmarzahn und der hatte irgendwie so diese Wurstscheiben, die dann so an den Ecken so nach oben gehen. Und da hat er die irgendwie so Geflügelwurst genannt, weil es so aussieht wie ein Flugzeug oder irgendwie so. Ja, ja. Keine Ahnung. War auf jeden Fall nervig. Aber da ist, glaube ich, meine Liebe zur Comedy entstanden
und gestorben und dann wieder entstanden während dieser ganzen
einen Folge. Ich habe gerade die Mail bekommen,
hat mich ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gebracht,
gerade eben,
Hey Stefan, deine Highlights der Woche
von Sky. Und jetzt haben die
mir einfach gesagt, was meine Highlights der Woche
sein werden oder waren. Augenscheinlich
das Konzert von Xavier Naidoo
Live,
24 Legacy, niemand kennt dich so gut wie deine Spam-Mails, Battlestar Galactica und Castle Staffel 1-8. Das sind meine Highlights. Er hat nicht so viel Zeit dieses Wochenende, deswegen sagen wir erst mal nur 1-8. Aber warum ist Staffel 1-8 ein Highlight? Sollten die nicht sagen, Castle Staffel 1, Folge 3? Das stimmt, ja. Das ist dein Highlight. Ein fucking langes Highlight. Ja, das stimmt schon. 1 bis 8, das ist alle gut.
Was ist eine blöde Mail?
Sowas macht mich wütend im Alltag.
Da möchte ich kurz betonen.
Apropos wütende Mails, wir haben ganz viele tolle Nachrichten von euch bekommen.
Wütende Nachrichten.
Leider haben wir das letzte Mal,
die Folge war sehr leise,
viele Leute haben sich wieder beschwert.
Haben uns laut zurückgeschrieben.
Wir nennen sie liebevoll die Mäusefolge.
Und, halt mal dran.
Die Rubrik
heisst
Startup-Apps.
Unsere neue Rubrik,
wo wir 20 Euro
verlosen. Viel Spaß!
Ja, wir haben
von euch fantastische Mails bekommen. Es sind zu zu viele wir konnten sie noch nicht komplett sortieren deswegen möchten wir das ganze auf die nächste woche verschieben genauso wie wir die ganzen binky sagt boo stories auf nächste woche verschieben ja genau alles in der richtung deswegen vielen dank dafür der zwani ist auf jeden fall warm er liegt schon auf der heizung und ist bereit in eure hände geschickt zu werden aber. Aber falls ihr noch weitere Startup-Ideen habt für eine tolle App, die ihr entwickeln könnt, dann schickt sie uns. Genau, wir verlosen 20 Euro und mit einem unterschriebenen Schein. 20 Euro. Meinerweise ist er mal vom EZB-Chef, Mario Draghi ist seine Unterschrift drauf und dann einfach von uns. Wie oft hat der seine Unterschrift geübt, bevor der die auch alle Scheine gleichzeitig gemacht hat? Er hat auch, wie viel Zeit musste er haben, dass er die auf alle Scheine schreiben konnte. Ich weiß noch damals, als er mit 16 meinen Personalausweis bekommen hat und es hieß, ja da ist jetzt eine Unterschrift drauf und ich hatte mir bis zu dem Zeitpunkt intensive Gedanken über meine Unterschrift gemacht und dachte mir, fuck, da hat er mir so einen Zettel gegeben, so, ja kannst du schon mal üben und es waren die stressigsten 40 Minuten meines Lebens, wie ich da saß und meine Unterschrift geübt habe und dachte mir, okay, das ist jetzt meine Unterschrift. Das ist auch der Grund, warum man am Amt so lange sitzt, wartet, weil wenn man reingeht kurz um zu gucken, was ist da eigentlich los, 80 so minderjährige Leute, die wie wild ihre Unterschrift üben, schwitzend und dann ihre Unterschrift üben. Aber das Resultat lustigerweise bei dir ist einfach, Florentin will in Druckbuchstaben und das E von Florentin ist das Eurozeichen. Richtig. Fand ich eine spannende Idee. Aber hast du das erzählt, dass die meisten Menschen nicht mit ihrer anatomisch korrekten Stimme sprechen? Ja, habe ich erzählt. Das haben wir beim Sprechtraining gelernt. Die meisten Leute sprechen etwas höher oder tiefer, als eigentlich ihr Sprangraum, ihre Sprangquelle, ihre Sprachverrichtung
vorsieht, tatsächlich.
Und das hat dann soziale Gründe, warum man...
Ja, das hat nur soziale Gründe. Tiere machen das normal,
weil die nicht, weil die weder eitel sind,
meistens, außer die Pfauen.
Pfauen sind schon schlimm. Aber alle anderen Tiere,
die sind halt entspannt, die haben
keine äusseren Einflüsse, die sich so sehr beeinflussen,
dass sie das nicht ändern, ihre Stimme ändern.
Aber ich finde es so lustig, weil dann gehst du zur Sprachtherapie und merkst so, hey, ich habe mein ganzes Leben lang viel zu hoch gesprochen und dann kommst du am nächsten Tag zu arbeiten und sagst, hallo Leute. So spreche ich jetzt. Da denkst du dich, hä, was ist denn jetzt los, warum spricht der jetzt so anders? Weil ich meine, das sind wahrscheinlich soziale Gründe, warum man sich dann irgendwo, aber irgendwann muss man sich auf so eine Stimme entscheiden, dann kann man nicht mehr zurückrudern. Gerade wir über hundert Folgen Podcasts in der Welt, wir können jetzt nicht einfach sagen und am nächsten Tag anfangen zu sagen so, hallo Leute, hey, das ist eine Stimme, viel Spaß, ja, das geht nicht, das funktioniert einfach nicht. Und hat nicht sogar deine homophobische Sprachlehrerin gesagt, das Schwuletten, besonders auch oft in so einem hohen Sprachdiktus. Sie hat das Wort Schwuchteln benutzt, das waren, das ist tatsächlich, homosexuelle Männer sprechen meistens höher, einfach weil sie sich auch darüber identifizieren und oft anders identifizieren als die homosexuelle Männer. Warum gibt es da so viele, warum gibt es diesen, ja gut, es gibt auch Lesbenvorurteile, aber jetzt nicht so krass, nicht so diesen Habitus, ja gut, dass vielleicht diese bruschasen Männer, Mann, Mannzweiber, das ist. Doch, es gibt schon kurze Haare, Achselshirts, haben Holzarbeit im Haus. Aber diesen Sprechduktus nicht so, so ein Schwulen kannst du immer normal spielen, oh Gott, ich habe das richtig schlecht gefühlt. Aber eine Lesbe? Ja, spiel mal eine Lesbe. Hallo Leute. Ich glaube, das Problem ist für Männer einfach, eine Lesbe zu sprechen. Ja, aber auch eine Frau kann eine Lesbe nicht gut sprechen, du kannst es schlecht sagen, so. Ich finde, das gehört auch gar nicht mit dieser Zeit. Es gehört auch gar nicht mit dieser Zeit. Nein, natürlich nicht, aber es ist ja, ja, aber anscheinend ist ja bei schwulen Männern der Fall, dass sie ihre Sprache verändern, bei Lesben anscheinend noch nicht so stark. Ich glaube auch, dass lesbische Frauen dann vielleicht einfach tiefer sprechen, weil die tiefe Stimme von als Maskulin gilt in der Gesellschaft und deswegen... Wollen Lesben unbedingt maskulin sein? Das ist eine Frage, wie man sich selber definiert. Und wenn homosexuelle Männer sich eher weniger über ihre Maskulinität definieren, dann sprechen sie dementsprechend wahrscheinlich höher. Ich finde das auch spannend, das hat mich auch vom Hocker gehauen. Ich werde beim Thema Sexualität und homophob und so mega nervös, weil man immer Angst hat, irgendwas Falsches zu sagen. Man hat immer Angst, in irgendeine feministische Falle zu tappen und dann sagt man wieder, ja, und dann gerade so, wie man über das Problem denkt, ist Teil des Problems. Aber so geht es mir auch mit Rassentheorien. Ja, mega. Sobald du sagst, ja, Schwarze haben halt nun mal einen grossen Penis, dann denkt man im Kopf bildet sich dann immer so, ist das wirklich so? Oder, ja, Schwarze laufen halt nun mal schneller die 100 Meter. Ja, weil die einfach in ihren Muskeln einfach mehr Fast-Twitch-Nerven-Muskelstränge haben. Es gibt ja zwei Arten von Muskelsträngen, einmalmal die schnell zucken und die die langsamer zucken, aber dafür länger ausdauernd sind. Und deswegen ist es tatsächlich so, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Usain Bolt, ein Sprinter, wenn der einen Marathon laufen würde, würde der danach nicht mehr so schnell sprinten können, weil seine Muskeln diese Fast-Twitch-Fasern ersetzen durch diese Slow-Twitch-Fasern. Hat das auch was mit seiner Nationalität zu tun? Ja, Nationalität nicht, aber halt durch seine Rasse. Schöne gute Rasse einfach mal. Das ist einfach eine rein rassige... Fühlt man sich da nicht schlecht einfach? Ich fühl mich dann jetzt gerade, auch wenn ich sage, ist Homosexualität vielleicht auch einfach genetisch bedingt, dann fühlt man sich auch so ein bisschen falsch einfach. Ein so tot tiefes Loch, oder?
Na ja, gut, das ist jetzt schwierig zu sagen, da kommst du auch nicht zu einer klaren Antwort.
Aber ich glaube, bei Afrikanern kann man durchaus sagen, dass gerade, dass sie halt irgendwie auch jeden Morgen zwölfeinhalb Kilometer sprinten müssen, um überhaupt Wasser zu bekommen, dass man da ganz klar sagen kann, dass die halt gut sprinten können.
Fakt ist, glaube ich, wir können den Schluss der Stimme machen unter der Diskussion, in dem man sagt, Hitler war schon nicht so falsch.
Richtig, absolut. Also Hitler hatte schon ziemlich recht viel mit vielen Dingen in seiner Rassentheorie. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe eine Powerbank, die ich sehr stolze bin. Es ist eine Powerbank und weiß auch kein Mensch, was das ist, oder genau? Das ist auch so ein Ding. Das ist eine große Lithium-Ionen-Batterie. Aber wie funktioniert eine Batterie? Kein Mensch weiß, wie eine Batterie funktioniert. Ja, vor allem, ich hatte mal ein Problem, dass ich zum ersten Mal nach New York wollte eine haben, für New York, und dann habe ich mir eine gekauft und dann hieß es, die kann man im Handgepäck auch gar nicht transportieren unbedingt, aber konnte man dann doch ohne weiteres. Aber Lithium-Ionen, wo ich mir auch denke, wow, da schießen Ionen rumher. Ionen schießen in meinem Kopf immer, die bleiben nicht still, die schießen immer rumher. Ich finde, Batterien ist praktisch gesehen ein so simples Konzept, du steckst irgendwas in die Steckdose an, das hat Strom. Ah, du steckst irgendeinen Behälter an die Steckdose an und da fließt dann Strom rein, so wie Wasser. Und dann nimmst du diesen Behälter mit und kannst dann diesen Strom benutzen. Das ist völlig nachvollziehbar, aber was genau da drin passiert, nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, keine Ahnung. Ich habe es im Chemieunterricht gelernt, nicht verstanden. Und ich habe so eine Powerbank und es ist wirklich so, dieses Ding ist 99% Powerbank und 1% Lampe. Da ist ein Lämpchen dran, einfach so als Taschenlampe, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum. Oh, das habe ich auch so ein Ding. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, warum eine Lampe dran ist, es ist einfach so an jedem Scheiß eine Taschenlampe. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch ein Radio, an dem auch eine Lampe dran ist. Ich habe so ein Klotzradio, wo du einfach so eine Lampe drücken kannst. Ich habe so eine ganz kleine Powerbank, so ein Werbegeschenk, was ich mir bekommen habe. Und das hat halt, das ist eine sehr kleine Powerbank, wo, glaube ich, das ist eher 50% Powerbank, 50% Taschenlampe. Vielleicht ist es einfach eine Taschenlampe mit einem sehr großen Akku, weiß ich nicht, aber dann ist da so eine LED dran. Und seitdem man herausgefunden hat, dass LEDs keine Energie verschwenden, hat man die ja überall hingesetzt. Seitdem gibt es Millionen LEDs. Übrigens Funfact, beim Eurovision Song Contest in Moskau, ich glaube 2009 oder 2008 oder so, noch nicht so lange her jedenfalls, wurden ein Drittel der auf der Welt verfügbaren LEDs verbaut. What? Ja, ein Drittel der auf der Welt verfügbaren LEDs waren in der Bühne des Eurovision Song Contests verbaut. Ja, und wo sind die jetzt? Wurden die nicht wieder verteilt? Exakt, das ist auch meine Frage. Ich glaube, damals waren die einfach noch nicht so sehr verbreitet, es wurden einfach mehr hergestellt irgendwann, und ich glaube, Wochen danach waren es schon ein Dreizigstel oder so. Aber das ist schon ein krasser Effekt, der auch wahrscheinlich einfach komplett falsch ist. Aber ich musste für dieses Powerbank muss man dreimal draufdrücken, um die Lampe anzumachen. Und wenn ich nicht irgendwie nervös gewesen wäre, wie wild drauf rumgedrückt hätte, hätte ich niemals herausgefunden, dass es eine Lampe hat. Aber LED-Lampen ist wie früher Pfeifen. Wir hatten mal im Physikunterricht so ein paar Geräte, da gab es dann so diesen Tischtennisschläger, wo dann so ein Gummiball dran war mit so einer Schnur, wo man den so dotzen konnte. Ja. Oder dann so ein Korb. 80% meiner Jugend. Oder so ein Korb, wo man so einen Ball an der Schnur mit dem Korbchen auffangen könnte. Und unser Physiklehrer hat uns das. Fang den Ball im Becher, heisst das Spiel. Ich weiß nicht, wie schlecht das Budget unserer Schule war, dass das Inhalt des Physikunterrichts war. Und dann hier ein Pfeil und Bogen. Und an jedem dieser Dinge war auch noch eine Pfeife dran. Das war einfach so, und dann hat er so ausgepackt, so ein Fernglas und da war noch eine Pfeife dran, so direkt dran. Und er hat mir gesagt, ja hier sind so eine Pfeife dran, ich weiß nicht warum und hat reingepfiffen so. Und wir dachten, es ist so lustig, dass an allem noch so eine Pfeife drin ist und dass es einfach so eine Überproduktion an Pfeifen gab. Wir bauen überall Pfeifen dran, das ist die Zukunft. Pfeifen sind die Zukunft. Mehr Pfeifen! Aber ich glaube, das ist das Prinzip Besitzaufkleber. Hier in der BTF haben wir ja überall kleine BTF-Aufkleber auf dem ganzen Eigentum der Firma. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Prinzip, wenn es jemand Fremdes findet, klar, testet der die Pfeife aus und dann kommt sofort jemand an von der Schule, sammelt das ein und bringt es wieder zurück. Sofort kommt jemand, das ist Rückversicherung. Sofort kommt jemand angelaufen, nehmt die, sorry, das geht uns, und läuft wieder zurück. Ich dachte mal, dass das so ein Hype war. Es gibt ja auch so Was ist was Bücher über Atomenergie, wo dann drinsteht, ja so in zehn Jahren ist in jeder Kaffeemaschine ein Atomreaktor, weil man nur noch mit Atomenergie arbeiten wird, was halt heutzutage lächerlich ist. Aber damals haben die sich halt wirklich so vorgestellt, weil auch Computer waren mal riesig, dann klein. Also warum nicht sagen, Atomkraftwerk war riesig und irgendwann ist es halt in jedem Computer ist ein kleines Atomkraftwerk drin. Der Gedanke ist nicht so dumm, aber rückblickend halt doof, aber einfach die Idee, dass man sagt, Pfeifen sind gerade ein Mega-Hype, in fünf Jahren ist überall eine Pfeife, du kannst keine Tür mehr betätigen, ohne dass eine Pfeife noch an der Türklopft an ist, war einfach gut. Aber... Ganz kurz zu dem Ball im Becher, den du eben sagst. Das ist hängen geblieben. Sorry. Und zwar ist das ein Spiel, das heißt, das ist dieser kleine Basketball-ähnliche Korb, wo du unten so eine Vorrichtung hast, wo du draufdrückst. Ja, wie so eine Heistüte. Genau, und du musst den Ball wieder fangen. Das ist ein kleiner Plastikball. Und dieses Spiel heißt Fang den Ball im Becher. Und das heißt, kaufe, ich hätte gern Fang den Ball im Becher mal zwei. Ich hätte gern zweimal Fang den Ball. Du musst so im Laden reagieren. Das heißt, die haben sich nicht die Mühe gemacht, das jemals zu nennen, sondern das Spiel heißt einfach so und erklärt sich selbst. Das ist wie die Gebrauchsanleitung des Spiels als Name des Spiels, was ich clever finde. Das ist nicht dumm. Das sagt mir sofort, was ich damit machen soll. Und jede Zweckentfremdung, wie soll ich das irgendwo einfach, ich weiß nicht, will ich nur abschießen, nein. Das erklärt sofort, was es ist. Fang den Ball im Becher. Ich hätte gerne einmal Würfel, solange bis du pleite bist, statt Monopoly einfach so. Einfach gute Möglichkeiten. Ich hätte gerne einmal dieses Bundespiel, wo man so lange bunte Figuren hin und her schieben muss, bis man sich gegenseitig ins Gesicht spucken will. Ja, genau. Sieh mal, Mensch, ärgere dich nicht. Richtig. Nein, was ich eben gesagt habe. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe diese Powerbank mit dieser kleinen LED-Lampe dran und es hat mich nie gestört. Und du konntest diese LED-Lampe anmachen, dann hast du zweimal draufgedrückt, dann hat die geblinkt, dann hast du dreimal draufgedrückt, dann hat die irgendwie, ey Macarena in Morse Code oder holt mich hier raus, ich bin in einer Powerbank gefangen, in Morse Code gemacht oder was auch immer. Aber mittlerweile ist dieses Ding kaputt gegangen und die geht von allein an immer wieder, die LED-Lampe, die geht konstant von allein an, muss man die ausmachen und dann geht die wieder von allein an. Und ich habe gemerkt, dass die einfach keinen Strom verbraucht, nichts. Die kann Wochen und Monate lang brennen und die verbraucht keinen Strom, es macht keinen Unterschied, die hat immer so eine Anzeige, so fünf Lichter und dann noch vier und drei und die machen keinen Unterschied. Deswegen, ich trage die immer in meinem Rucksack rum und die ist jetzt einfach immer an, die leuchtet immer, konstant. Und es ist jetzt echt immer so der Effekt, dass immer wenn ich meinen Rucksack aufmache, der von innen einfach beleuchtet ist, immer die ganze Zeit, wie ein Kühlschrank. Ja, es ist so dieser Pulp Fiction Moment, das ist so das Ding und es ist einfach immer schön, auch so in der U-Bahn oder so, du holst irgendwie eine Flasche aus deiner Rucksack raus und es ist halt beleuchtet. So ein strahlender Lichtstrahl und so. Aber es ist einfach praktisch, weil es ist zu nervig, das immer wieder auszumachen. Das heißt, es brennt konstant. Mich würde es wütend machen, wenn die Powerbank leer ist und du hast keinen Strom gerade und bist sauer, weil dein Handy ist leer, dein Macbook ist leer, aber du siehst diese kleine LED, die sind der Mittelfinger der Powerbank, die ihn gegenstrengt. So, fuck it, ich gehe noch. Dafür habe ich noch Energie.
Ja, ich habe fast genug. Und es ist tatsächlich sehr praktisch, immer ein Licht in seinem Rucksack zu haben. Es ist immer gut, auch einfach reinzugreifen, du siehst, was drin ist, wunderbar, perfekt. Also ich glaube, eigentlich, ich kann es vielleicht sogar als Weisheit der Woche präsentieren. Wenn ihr eine Powerbank habt. Nein, das ist ein Jingle, ey. Wenn ihr eine Powerbank. Ich muss das eigene Bein. Wenn ihr eine Powerbank habt und mit LED dran, dann haltet die einfach konstant an und tut die so in euren Rucksack. Oder eine Handtasche oder ein Auto oder so. Oder macht so ein Gaffatepe drum. Nee, einfach immer an, da ist immer der Raum beleuchtet, wie ein Kühlschrank. Ja, aber ich dachte mir, du musst den Finger draufgerückt halten, um die anzulassen. Nee, gar nicht. Konstant. Die drückst du an, dann ist die an. Du warst ja letztens in einem Kofferraum. Ja, genau, wollte ich gerade sagen. Ich war neulich für einen Dreh, auf den ihr euch besonders freuen könnt, war ich im Kofferraum und wurde in einem Kofferraum lange Zeit gehalten, wo ich mir dachte, also dieser Dreh war ein Mysterium für mich, weil ich bin ja nicht so mega oft auf Drehs, hab schon so ein bisschen was mitbekommen, aber ich war noch nie bei so einem brutalen Dreh, wo ich einen Großteil im Kofferofferraum verbringen musste, später noch hinfallen musste usw. Und da kommt man sich auch manchmal so vor, als ob, man fragt sich kontinuierlich, wissen die gerade, dass man das kann die ganze Zeit? Darf man als Mensch so lange im Kofferraum sitzen? Weil ich war die Grossteile des Abends, es war stockfinster, es war kalt, ich hatte nichts an und war im Kofferraum. Also viele Fragen werden sich an ihrem Kopf bilden, die werden alle noch beantwortet. Schaut mal bei Gute Arbeit Originals vorbei. Und ja, dann war es halt so, dass ich in dem Kofferraum lag und ich fand es eigentlich ganz lustig, hatte auch ein Grinsen im Gesicht, weil ich es ganz cool fand. Und dann merkt man so langsam, wie dieser gleisender Benzingeruch in die Nase steigt. Und der Wagen war an und da fährt man herum. Das war alles cool, so was wie eine coole Achterbahnfahrt im Dunkeln. Aber dieser Benzingeruch lässt dann noch irgendwie fragen, haben die sich das vorher überlegt, ob man das eigentlich stirbt jetzt einfach? Und dann andere Sache, ich musste hinfallen. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, die haben sich bestimmt coole Klanken gemacht. Also ich meine, mein Kopf sollte auf dem Asphalt landen. Da dachte ich mir, ja, das ist ein cooler Effekt, wenn man sowas mal von sich sieht, ist schon ganz geil, wie macht man das, hat man da eine Matte, hat man da, wie fällt man da runter, ich meine, das ist schon cool, das mal zu erleben, wie man das so macht, hinter den Kulissen, nee, du musst schon richtig fallen, hieß es dann, und ich habe auch gedacht, ist das wirklich, nee, du musst richtig von einem Meter ungefähr auf den Boden fallen, das machen wir aber nur zweimal, so, dann habe ich abends im Bett, habe ich das geübt, wie ich dann mich hinknie und dann runterfalle. Und es war halt im Bett und tat es übertrieben weh, weil ich falle halt 1,80 tief. Das ist nur nicht wie auf eine Matratze zu fallen. Das hat weh getan. Ich fall tief. Ich fall tief. Das sage ich dir. Wenn ich knie, bin ich 1,80 groß. Immer noch. Wenn ich dann einmal umqualle, dann ist es wie, als ob ein Mensch einfach umkippt, wo man von der Tür rennt. Aber im Endeffekt war es halt so schlimm. Aber der grösste Funfact, den ich in meinem Leben wahrscheinlich jemals erzählen werde, erzählen werden kann, ist, dass im Kofferraum, wenn der Kofferraum zugeht, das Licht angeht. Es ist das Gegenteil eines Kühlschranks. Das Licht geht an, wenn im Kofferraum die Klappe zugemacht wird. So, und das hat Stefan gesagt beim
Dreh, und niemand hat es ihm geglaubt,
aber er war leider in der Verlegenheit,
es schlicht nicht beweisen zu können.
Rein technisch konnte er seinen
Worten keine Weile. Und ich finde das grossartig.
Ich weiß etwas, was vielleicht drei, vier Leute
auf der Welt wissen noch. Und wie also Stefan,
du bist doch scheiße, du bist doch dumm, du bist doch behindert.
Und er so, nein, nein, nein, nein,
so halt, wie man ihn kennt. Und dann halt irgendwie, aber er konnte es nicht beweisen einfach. Aber ich finde es so geil, es ist so ein erlesener Kreis aus Leuten, weil die meisten überleben diese Situation nicht. Die meisten, die im Kofferraum sind, werden den Tag nicht mehr erleben. Die werden umgebracht vorher. Ich kann als einziger von ungefähr fünf, sechs Leuten, würde ich mal behaupten, auf der Welt sagen mit Sicherheit und möchte dieses Wissen an euch weitergeben, dass im Kofferraum das Licht angeht, wenn es zugemacht wird. Das stimmt eigentlich, du bist unter den ein Prozent der Kofferraumüberlebenden. Ja. Das stimmt eigentlich schon, ne? Ja, ich glaube, es wird mehr gedreht, oder? Na ja, was da die ganze Yakuza und die ganze Mafia und so da wegballern jeden Tag. Ja, ja. Ich finde es schon cool. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall, es gibt kein schöneres Gefühl auf der Welt, als Auto zu fahren, wenn man weiß, dass Stefan Tietze im Kofferraum ist und der Regisseur so, ja, leg mal ruhig noch einen Gang drauf. Einfach okay, um die Ecke. Mach es mal authentisch nach, wie er gesprochen. Ja, dann machen wir noch eine Einstellung. Fahr drüber ein bisschen schneller, liegt er mal ein bisschen drauf. muss ja zusagen, wir haben uns heute diese Walkie-Talkies gekauft und ich habe schon so auf dem Rückweg schelmen, wie ein Schelm gesagt, wow, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir jetzt den Polizeifunk mithören könnten, wie cool wäre das eigentlich, das ist so ein Babyphone, einfach so ein sterbendes Baby hören, da ist ein Babyphone und da. Und dann haben wir es einfach in den Relationenraum gelegt,
unsere Walkie-Talkies, und plötzlich
aus dem Nichts gingen die an.
Und wir haben die Baustelle nebenan gehört.
Wir haben Leute von der Baustelle nebenan
reden gehört. Leider sind es alles
Ausländer und die sprechen furchtbares Deutsch und
durch diesen verzerrten Ton hat man gar nichts mehr verstanden.
Wir haben denen aber trotzdem Anweisungen gegeben, was sie
jetzt zu bauen haben und dass sie endlich mal die Säge,
die laute Säge ausmachen sollen.
So, klang das die ganze Zeit. Nonsens! Oder besweichere? Regional Express 13, nach Güterslohn, am Westfalen, Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung rechts. Bitte passen Sie auf, momentan treiben sich Trickbetriebe und Diebe auf dem Bahnsteig herum, bitte passen Sie auf Ihre persönlichen Gegenstände auf und verdächtigen Sie alle Ausländer. Vielen Dank, Ihre Deutsche Bahn AG-Stimm. Das ist auch sehr laut. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man es leiser bekommt. Ich glaube, wir sind allen tischisch auf die Nerven gegangen. Aber das ist auch so ein Ding, wenn ich das, ich bin ja recht häufig auf Bahnhöfen, weil ich immer zwischen Köln und Hamburg rotiere und da höre ich auch oft diese Anweisung, so dieses Es sind Diebe und Trickbetrüger und Trickdiebe. Es gibt verschiedene Begriffe, es gibt Diebe, Trickdiebe und Trickbetrüger auf dem Bahnsteigen unterwegs. Und Trickzauberer, das ist immer die Ansage immer, achten Sie dem Trickzauberer, das ist ein großer Spaß für die ganze Familie. Vor allem ich denke mir immer so, diese Durchsage wird doch immer gemacht, nachdem ein Diebstahl stattgefunden hat. Klar. Also, falsch, zur falschen Zeit.
Du willst doch die Ansage machen, bevor der Diebstahl stattfindet. Dann bist du beklaut, dann läufst du dahin zur Anzeige und dann machst du das. Das heißt, eigentlich müsste man so random tagsüber, es sind momentan Diebe auf dem Bahnsteig und alle Diebe denken sich, oh fuck, scheiße, die wissen von mir, ich muss weg, noch bevor sie was klauen konnten. Ja genau, und ich finde das ist ein grossartiges Thema. Danke, dass du das ansprichst. Weil achtet mal darauf, wenn am Bahnsteig, wenn am Bahnsteig steht nachts um zwei Uhr, Köln am Neumarkt, und dann kommt diese, dann steht ja da mit so 13 Leuten, die alle da stehen, sich die ganze Zeit angucken. Die sind Chloido-Spiel. Die ganze Zeit angucken, und dann plötzlich kommt diese Durchsage, Achtung, es sind gerade Trickbetrüger unterwegs und Taschendiebe, achten sie besonders auf ihr Material. Und plötzlich fehlt nur noch so eine Sherlock-Melodie, plötzlich drehen sich alle so ein bisschen um und niemand traut mir irgendwen, das ist wie Hateful Eight. Und man steht da am Bahnsteig, guckt sich um, ernst, und ich achte auch immer darauf, ich gucke dann wirklich lange diesen Mann an der Rechtsphäre, der mich genauso mustert wie ich ihn, und ich frage mich, bist du es? Und er fragt sich, ist er es? Und dann steht man da und man achtet darauf. Ich habe dann herausgefunden, in meinem Kopf hat derjenige, der Portemonnaies klaut, sehr viele Taschen. Er hat unfassbar viele Taschen, die bereits gefüllt sind in meinem Kopf, was ja auch nicht so richtig ist, weil die klauen wahrscheinlich nicht 80 Portemonnaies, bevor sie sie nach Hause gehen und die abliefern oder so. Oder wo gehen die hin? Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, die haben einfach wahrscheinlich nur, sie sehen ganz normal aus und möglichst normal, haben keine Tasche mit und vielleicht nur, stecken das einfach nur ein in ihre Tasche vielleicht, weil die wollen ja nicht auffallen. Ja, stimmt schon. Vor allem, ich denke mir immer so, die Diebe, ist das für die cool, dann so eine Ansage? Ist das wegen, hey, wir sind die berichtigen Diebe cool, oder ist das so eine Niederlage, ist das wie so ein Game Over, wie so bei so einem Schleichspiel bei Metal Gear Solid, wo du dann irgendwie erkannt wirst, ist es dann Game Over, dann müssen wir alle nach Hause ziehen und dann so, okay, morgen wieder. Ja, da fängt man nicht genau dann erst an. Ist das nicht der Moment, wo sich alle am sichersten fühlen? Ja, oder dann kommen die Mörder. Wenn alle auf die Diebe achten, dann kommen die Mörder. Und andersrum, wenn sie sagen, äh, entschuldigen Sie bitte einen Mörder auf den Mörder auf Flasme. Kommen sie aus ihren Löchern gekrochen. Die Gefürchteten. Wie so gekriecht, gibt hier. Direkt Schwarzfahrer, ey. Ich hasse Schwarzfahrer. Aber das ist ziemlich grossartig, diese Durchsage. Ich bin auch immer, ich verdächtige an immer jedem. Du kannst dir keiner mehr trauen. Ja Ja, ich stelle mich dann einfach immer mit dem Rücken zur Wand. Ja. Man klaut mich die Wand. Also einfach so, das ist einfach immer gut. Das will, genau die Wand will, dass du dieses Gefühl hast. Ja. Kriminalität. Ja, ich achte da halt auch primär auf Ausländer. Bin ich ganz ehrlich, tut mir auch wahnsinnig leid, und ich weiß, dass es falsch ist, aber es ist halt in meiner DNA drin, in meinem Kopf drin, in meiner Rasse. Ich als weisser Deutscher beschuldige den Jud und den Türk, und dann stehen die halt da am Bahnsteig, und ich weiß, ah, der war's doch. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber man macht's halt leider. Leider Gottes. Ja, stimmt. Es merkt man auch, wenn dann übrigens einer von denen näher kommt und man dann sich immer so wegdreht. Ich hab manchmal das Gefühl schon so, dass ich mich dann, weil der Gäbeutel ist ja hinten an einem, so dass man immer, wenn man jemanden des Diebstahls beschuldigt, man sich ihm zuwenden muss. Und das ist Leuten manchmal unangenehm und dadurch bewegen sie sich wieder in eine andere Position und dann muss man wieder die Position ändern, wodurch so ein langer Tanz entsteht, dass so eine scheinbar verdächtige Person immer um mich rum, in so einer Rosenform, so immer um mich rumbounce. Irgendwann umarmt ihr euch und tanzt herzlich und machen Musik dazu. Aber es ist dann so, ich denke mir immer, in dem Moment verdächtigt er mich auch, weil ich mich auch auffällig verhalte. Und plötzlich ist es so eine Self-Affiz-Prophecy und alle fangen an, sich gegenseitig zu beklauen, nur weil sie nicht selber beklaut werden wollen. So ein Präventivdiebstahl. Präventiv-Tanz. Leute fangen plötzlich an, einfach um sich herum zu schlängeln. Das ist wie so ein Paarungstanz. Ich glaube nur, dass es besser wäre, die auch häufiger einfach mal random durchzusagen, ohne dass davor schon was passiert ist. Präventiv. Das ist auch bei Blitzern so. Ich verstehe nicht, warum man das sagt. Wenn die Idee ist, der Staat will, dass vernünftig gefahren wird auf den Strassen und man stellt Blitze auf, um Leute zu ermahnen, die es nicht tun. Warum lässt man die im Radio Bahn vor Blitzern? Ich verstehe das nicht. Das ist die Frage, ist da eigentlich die Polizei dagegen, dass solche Dinge gemacht werden? Nein, die wollen das ja sogar, habe ich gehört. Ja, damit der halt langsam gefahren wird. Ja, aber das erreichen sie doch gerade, wenn man da, dann fährt man, dann fahren die Leute doch nur da langsam. Und überall scheissen sie drauf, weil sie genau wissen, da stehen die Blitzer. Wohingegen, wenn sie da ermahnt werden, einmal ohne zu wissen, einfach knallhart in den Blitzer reinfahren, werden sie doch, also ich fahre langsamer an Orten, wo ich schon geblitzt wurde. Ich weiß nicht genau, was das soll. Wenn man ein Polizist draußen hat, ich würde das echt mal gerne in Erfahrung bringen, ob das irgendwie empirisch bewiesen ist, dass es hilft mehr in der Gesellschaft. Ich glaube, das trägt nicht dazu bei, sondern eher, dass man da halt präventiv langsamer fährt,
aber das nur das eine Mal und nur an den Orten, wo man weiß, dass da Bitzer stehen.
Ich verstehe das nicht genau.
Verkehrspolizist ist das echt langweiligste, was es gibt, ey.
Ich denke mal, bei jedem Verkehrspolizist ist so schade, ey, sorry.
Der will doch bestimmt auch irgendwie Verbrecher jagen oder Banditen hinterherlaufen und auf Laub unterwegs sein. Polizas Neustadt, bitte schau an zum Rechtsrufer, danke. Das ist das Coole daran, die haben oben diese Lautsprecher und da können sie mit reden, laut. Ist das so? Lauter sprechen. Das ist doch toll. Ja, hau du mal eine geile Anekdote raus, Stefan. Hier beim Wochenende alle drei Teile hätte Ringe geguckt, nacheinander. Und das sind so die Sachen, wo man erst das für eine gute Idee hält und es cool findet. Man aber am Ende Teil eins merkt, ja, ich will ja auch, dass der Film jetzt vorbei ist. Der Film will ja jetzt vorbei, deswegen endet der Film jetzt auch. Und es ist nicht dafür gemacht, dass man es nacheinander alle drei Teile guckt. Ja, das habe ich auch schon mal gemacht. Vor Hobbit, als wir uns den ersten Hobbit-Teil angeschaut haben, da haben wir alle drei Hände-Ringersteile gesehen und sind dann ins Kino gefahren, um der Hobbit zu schauen. Huiuiui, das hat aber noch schlimmer bei Harry Potter. Ja, holy fuck, das war auch der letzte Teil, das ist rausgekommen, da haben wir alle davor angeguckt und sind dann ins Kino gegangen. Heieiei, hat das lange gedauert. Vor allem bei Harry Potter kann man halt merken, dass es immer besser wird, weil es halt für einen ... Ja, und ich meine, du hast halt den Emma-Watson-Effekt. Ja. So, das ist schon okay. Man wird immer geiler. Ja, und es wird immer legaler, man muss sich immer weniger schämen für seine ... Ja, aber das ... Darin finde ich es krass, vor allem weil es sich ja auch viel wiederholt, am ersten Teil eines jeden Films, der nochmal den vorherigen aufgreift, um halt irgendwie auf eine natürlich tolle, spannende, innovative Art versucht, nochmal dem Viewer ins Gedächtnis zu rufen, was da passiert ist im ersten Teil.
Und das widerdoppelt sich einfach auch viel. Das ist einfach nicht dafür gemacht, man sollte eine neue Version gucken dann.
Natürlich die externe Version, die dann irgendwie acht Stunden lang sind. Und es wurde halt schnell, wurde die Stimmung im Raum, rapide schlechter und dann gab es dann noch, dann waren da sehr viele, sehr viele, von wow geil, Lego, lass zu, bring jetzt, schmeiß den endlich in den scheiss Berg hinein, ey. Und vor allem ist Frodo einfach auch ein Unsympath, muss man ganz zu sagen, der Protagonist ist unsympath, Sam ist der coolste Typ. Ja, eben. Aber dann funktioniert es wieder, solange der Sidesap ist wie bei uns. So, die Hauptfigur ist unsympathisch, aber der Sidekick ist cool. Wer ist jetzt der Sidekick in deinem Kopf? Ja, das kann sich jetzt jeder. Natürlich, natürlich. Aber das finde ich echt spannend. Da waren Mädchen dabei, die ganz klischeehaft einfach sich nicht für Herr der Ring interessiert haben, sondern fürs Essen und drumherum, die es dann zu einem Event machen wollten, was ich erst furchtbar fand, weil ich halt in so einem Herr der Ringe Fieber war und dachte mir, komm, wir gucken das jetzt und wenn, dann müsste es rohen Fisch und Kaninchensuppe geben. Und Lämbas, ja. Und Lämbasbrot, aber dann haben die die ganzen Referenzen nicht verstanden, war in der WhatsApp-Gruppe kein Lacher, kam keine Smilies zurück, kam keine Tränen in den Smilies zurück. Es kommen selten Menschen mit Tränen, wenn ich ihnen Witz erzähle. Dann haben die angefangen, erst Tacos, die Nachos zu überbacken, dann gab es irgendwann Pizza, selbstgemachte, dann gab es irgendwann Apple Crumble und es war so, es war einfach ein lustiger Abend, aber mit coolem Essen, der aber rapide, deren primärer Inhalt primär genervt hat dann auch irgendwann. Naja, das war, das war meine Anekdote. Hey, man erlebt auch nicht jede Woche was. Nee, ist okay. Heißt aber, wir sind auch kein Anekdoten-Podcast, wir sind ein kommender Podcast, wir können uns auch über andere Sachen lustig machen. Ja, ja, ja, aber Star Wars habe ich auch schon mal komplett durchgeschaut, aber dann in Veröffentlichungsreihenfolge, also erst vier, fünf, sechs, dann eins, zwei, drei. Das ist aber hart, ne? Das ist schon hart, ja. Wenn du die coolen, die Kronjuwelen am Anfang wegs, ne? Ja, schon wegballerst, ne? Ich weiß nicht, welche Filme sich da am ehesten für anbieten. Die Twilight-Saga? Ich glaube, dies gut zu gucken.
Der erste Twilight war kein schlechter Film.
Nie gesehen.
Der war nicht so schlecht, da waren ein paar gute Szenen drin. Herzlich willkommen zu Flo Dantins Filmecke. Heute Twilight. In Twilight geht es um die junge Frau Isabella Swan, die von ihrer Familie getrennt wird und zu ihrem Vater nach Kanada fährt. Kannst du das Ganze ein bisschen emotional machen, bitte? Danke. Und dann trifft sie auf Edward Snowden und muss ihn befreien. Das ist leider ein bisschen zu viel. Ich weiss nicht, ich fand ihn ganz gut eigentlich so, dass du so dieses Teenage-Angst und dieses Teenage-Gedöns und ich war auch ein Teenager und ich hatte auch irgendwie viele Vampire in meinem Leben und es ist immer so metaphorisch irgendwie, dann hat es gut gepasst, wenn man sich dachte so, ja, ach was, ich weiß es nicht. Das ist so dunkel auch einfach so, ich werde echt mega... Ja komm, wir machen mal Licht. Ich muss das schon fünfmal gähnen, weil es einfach so fucking dunkel ist.
Stefan wollte eine romantische Atmosphäre kreieren und hat irgendwie nur so ein paar Kerzen angemacht, sonst ist es dunkel, so, oh jetzt kommen wir schön die Neonlichter hier. Weißt du was, und dieses Licht, dieses Licht, was hier ist, dieses Licht macht alles falsch. Es ist nämlich nicht nur ein Licht, es ist einfach, es ist weiss, weisses Licht wie im OP. So jetzt sehe ich zum Beispiel dein Gesicht gerade und es macht mir tierische Angst. Und ich will gerade einen Arzt rufen, du hast ganz ungesunde Gesichtsfarbe, ich glaube, du hast, du ernährst dich, du ernährst dich mittlerweile auch anders. Kann man das mal eigentlich zum Thema machen? Dass du mittlerweile nicht mehr, dass du mittlerweile vegan bist? Ja, kann man mal. Kann man das zum Thema machen? Kann man mal hier revealen. Florentin nimmt nicht ab, er ist einfach nur vegan und ernährt sich jetzt anders. Und nimmt trotzdem nicht ab. Aber das ist ganz interessant. Ich hätte da Florentin zwei Wochen gegeben, er hat Neujahr angefangen und hat es bis jetzt schon durchgehalten. Er hat manchmal seine schwachen Momente, wo er schon ein bisschen traurig vom Kühlregal steht oder von Snacks und dann auch ein paar Tränchen vergiest. Ja, manchmal kaufe ich mir auch extra Chicken Nuggets, um sie dann anzustarren, dran zu riechen und dann den Gulli zu werfen. Einfach, um noch ein bisschen in alter Erinnerung zu schwelgen. Ich möchte aber auch kein moralischer Veganer sein. Also für mich ist es dann trotzdem wichtig, dass ich all die Tiere, die ich nicht esse, dann aber trotzdem in der Strassenecke zu Tode trete. Einfach, damit die Balance der Welt gesichert sein muss. Und ja, es ist furchtbar. Es ist furchtbar. Und du hast dir eine Woche gegönnt im Jahr, wo du Fleisch isst. Ja, ist richtig. Eine Woche im Sommer. Ich halte das für ein falsches Konzept. Ich werde einfach explodieren in dieser Woche. Ich werde einfach komplett ausrasten. Dein Körper wird nicht mehr gewohnt sein, nichts zu essen, was Fleisch bis Tiere beinhaltet. Und es wird dich, glaube ich, von innen auffressen auch. Das kann gut sein, dann schlagen die Tiere zurück und fressen mich auf. Das wäre cool, wenn in dieser einen Woche die Tiere dich auffressen. Ja, das wäre auch gut. Tiere? Tiere, wenn ihr ganz kurz jetzt... Ey, das mit den Walkie-Talkies war so eine scheisse Idee. Schauen Sie sich. Aber die reichen wahnsinnig weit, ne? Also ich habe heute Mater eingekauft und dann bin ich ein gutes Stück weggelaufen und die Mate hat immer noch funktioniert. Du konntest trotzdem eine Mate-Bestellung noch durchgeben durch die Walkie-Talkie, das war unfassbar.
Ich finde der Begriff Walkie-Talkie ist ein Begriff, finde ich, der anders als die meisten Worte, die irgendwann mal gebildet wurden, so cool ist einfach, weil das ist so süss, das ist lustig, das ist mit dem Lächeln quasi ausgedacht worden.
Da hat man so einen Kinderpädagoge, der sonst Schulbücher schreibt oder so, der hat sich gedacht, ich benenne das mal jetzt, Walkie Talkie. Walkie Talkie, das macht so viel richtig, es sagt dir, was es ist, es sagt dir, wie du es benutzen sollst, beim Gehen und Reden und es ist einfach so ein süsser kleiner Begriff. Es gibt auch dieses CB Radio, wo man dann selber irgendwie mit Radiowellen Kontakt aufnehmen konnte,
über irgendwelche Frequenzen gedönst oder irgendwas.
Warum spiel ich das Englische aus? CB Radio.
Ach, CB Radio, kann auch sein, ja stimmt.
Aber das ist auch so ein Ding, das ist schwer vorzustellen heutzutage,
dass man sich in den Wald gesetzt hat, abends seinen Kasten angeworfen hat,
einfach mit Leuten gesprochen hat, die irgendwie denselben, dasselbe Anti-Hobby hatten,
irgendwie das gemacht haben.
Und ich kann mich auch noch an die Fahrschule erinnern, wo das angesprochen wurde, weil man dazu anscheinend sehr große Antennen braucht auf seinem Auto. Und dann beim Thema Bahnübergang das vierstündige Seminar zum Thema Bahnübergang. Ja, aber was ist, wenn jetzt ein Auto fälschlicherweise auf dem Bahnübergang ist, muss man dann blinken, wenn man dann die Gleise wieder verlässt oder nicht?
Soll man dem helfen vor allem?
Ich weiß es doch nicht, mach da was du willst.
Und dann hieß es immer so, ja, jeder, der solche Antennen auf dem Dach hat, sollte auf jeden Fall die auf jeden Fall davor abschrauben, damit die nicht an den Stromabnehmer kommen und dann einfach mal durchgebraten wird.
Und bei uns kam die berechtigte Meldung so, und warum sollte man überhaupt diese Antennen haben, mit der Antwort, ja, manche mögen das. Was die Menschengruppe ganz gut zusammenfasst. Aber auch so ein interessantes, ich dachte auch nach der Fahrt schon, dass Sibirat ist und mit dem Leben ein wesentlich größeres Problem ist, als sie tatsächlich sind. Auf jeden Fall. Ich dachte auch so, dieses Verhältnis von eine Sekunde von der Bremswege berechnen und so, dachte ich, wäre auch ein viel grösserer Teil der Autofahrt tatsächlich, dass immer neben dem Fahrer noch jemand sitzt mit dem Taschenrechner und immer ausrechnet, so hey, übrigens 80 Meter Bremsweg und so. Ja, auch diese ganzen Flüssigkeitenwechsel, die ich alle gelernt habe, die ich dann auch in der Prüfung nicht brauchte, aber auch noch nie in meinem Leben, wie beim Autofahrerleben. Ich fahre bislang gut durch die Welt, viel durch die Welt, ich muss noch nicht einmal Öl wechseln, noch nicht einmal Fensterflüssigkeit nachfüllen. Das passiert einfach dann bei der Untersuchung, bei der Jahresuntersuchung, automatisch. Ich bin letztens einfach irgendwo, ich bin hingekommen, habe geparkt und habe gemerkt, dass es meistens ein Blinker an war. Und wahrscheinlich für die gesamte Fahrt ich einfach geblinkt habe. Ich bin einfach, ja gut, du bist halt auch ein kompletter Vollidiot einfach, du kannst es einfach schon lassen. Ja, ich wurde neulich mal durch Köln fahrend immer angeblend, angehupt von allen ich dachte, was ist denn jetzt los eigentlich, ich fahre doch wie sonst auch und dann plötzlich habe ich irgendwo angehalten an der Ampel, dann kamen wirklich ganz viele Leute zu einem, wenn meine Fenster die meine Fenster gleichzeitig runter gemacht haben und sie haben gesagt, ich habe kein Licht an und ich sollte doch bitte einfach mein Licht an machen und dann ändert sich komplett dein Weltbild, weil du das Problem hattest die ganze Zeit. Das ist echt nicht gut.
Es gibt so Momente, wo man sich einfach denkt, ich bin ein Trottel, ich bin einfach ein Vollidiot.
Also da kann man auch nicht mehr, und ich habe das Gefühl, diese Momente häufen sich.
Ich glaube, man wird einfach, und irgendwie wenn man im Seniorenalter ist, dann sagt man einfach, ja, ich bin jetzt zu 90 Prozent unbrauchbar.
Trottel.
Und man scheisst aber auch irgendwann drauf.
Ich glaube, dieses richtig alt ist man, wenn man irgendwie rückwärts aus der Einfahrt rausfährt und nicht mehr schaut, ob jemand kommt. Ja, es gibt ein Alter, die fahren einfach. Und ganz im Ernst, es macht nicht viel aus, weil Leute um dich herum alle, also eigentlich haben alle gelernt, auf den Verkehr zu achten. Das heißt, du kannst dir schon so ein bisschen Arschloch erlauben. Ich gucke mich oft um, bevor ich links rüberziehe und ziehe dann das Ried links rüber. Wenn ich langsam links rüberziehen würde einfach, würde auch nicht viel passieren, weil alle anderen Leute wollen auch nicht, dass ihr Auto kaputt geht. Heißt, oft erreicht man irgendwann ein Alter, ich würde sagen, es ist bei ungefähr 77, 78, wo man lernt, das ausleben zu können. Das heißt, ohne zu gucken und ohne eine Miele zu verziehen, ohne zu blinken, ohne die Geschwindigkeit zu verändern, zieht man einfach langsam ein bisschen links rüber. Und Leute reagieren darauf. Man fährt auch auf die Gegenspur einfach. Und man fährt auf den Lidl-Park mit 80 kmh und fuck it. Ja, es ist scheißegal. Die sollen sich nach mir richten. Und es ist eigentlich auch scheißegal, weil Leute reagieren ja darauf. Leute sind ja auch aufmerksam in der Umwelt.
Das ist einfach die falsche Moral, aber einfach mal so rüberziehen und denken, fuck, es passiert nichts.
Es passiert einfach nichts.
Ich habe auch letztens, da habe ich irgendwie Pommes, hatte ich Pommes während dem Autofahren.
Und ich habe angefangen, übrigens, Lifehack.
Der Podcast-Ufo-Lifeive-Fact der Woche lautet, einfach mal Pommes wie ein Burger essen. Was meine ich damit? In der Regel braucht man zum Pommes-Essen zwei Hände. In der linken Hand hat man die Pommes-Tüte, mit der rechten Hand stopft man sich einen Pommes-Stift nach dem anderen zwischen die Zähne. Meine Erfindung, die Pommes-Tüte mit festem Griff in der Hand haben und dann wie ein Burger so mit dem Mund die einzelnen Pommes rausziehen, sodass man nur eine Hand zum Pommes essen braucht. So fahre ich Auto durch Hamburg, so fahre ich durch die Gegend mit einer Hand Pommes, in der anderen Hand irgendwie salzige Heringe und fahre dann durch die Gegend und dann bin ich auch angekommen zu Hause und dann wollte ich den Müll von dieser Pommes-Tüte nicht mehr in meine Wohnung nehmen, weil das ist das Dümmste, was man machen kann, ist Müll in die Wohnung mitnehmen, ganz furchtbar. Auch immer, wenn ich irgendwas in einem Amazon-Paket von der Post hole, immer schon aufmachen und den Karton schon auf dem Weg nach Hause entsorgen und gar nicht erst mit nach Hause nehmen. So, und dann bin ich auf den, dann war ich kurz vor meiner Wohnung geparkt, 20 Meter bis zur Wohnung, dann war ich so auf 10 Meter meiner Wohnung dran, dann hatte ich diese Tüte in der Hand und habe sie einfach angeguckt, einfach am Boden gelegt, nicht geworfen, weil ich dachte mir, ich bin kein Barbar, ich bin keine Rüde. Du bist umweltbewusst, du willst den Boden nicht verletzen, du weckst sie hin. In dem Fall bin ich eingeschlafen und dachte mir, hey, bist du, also langsam ist ja echt alles scheiße, du bist echt ein Arschloch geworden. Ja, aber man muss sagen, das ist auch der Louis TK-Bit, ich weiss, Leute, die wieder in den Kommentaren wütende Kommentare schreiben, es ist nicht die Umwelt, die du da beschädigst. Ich meine, das ist nur Asphalt. Du wirst es nicht umweltschädigen, wenn du eine Plastiktüte in Hamburg wegwirfst. Nee, aber für alle anderen ist es natürlich scheisse. Ja gut. Wenn die Leute gegenlaufen und dann drüber stolpern, so wie ich über diesen Plastikringen gestolpert bin. Das war eine Sache. Das war verrückt. Plastikränge! Ja. Man wird Arschloch, aber man kann es sich auch ein bisschen erlauben, weil diese Sache mit, ja, wenn jetzt alle anderen so wären wie du, ist ein bisschen, da muss ich Kant auch widersprechen. Sind sie ja nicht. Sind sie ja nicht.
Und es ist einfach eine...
Endlich wurde Kant widerlegt, 300 Jahre hat es gedauert.
So, ich nehme mal kurz raus.
Wir widerlegen bekannte Persönlichkeiten.
Also, wenn man sagt,
streng genommen,
was du nicht willst, das man dir tut,
das fügt auch einem anderen zu,
ganz kategorischer Imperativ, der ein bisschen was anderes aussagt, aber ganz grob zusammengefasst. Ist eigentlich Quatsch. Kompletter Quatsch. Vergesst das. Weil ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt. Weil die werden es euch nicht zutun. Auch mit diesem Wählen. Wählen ist Quatsch, weil du hast nur eine Stimme. Weißt du, eine Stimme macht keinen Unterschied. Wählen. Scheißegal. Wählen, ja. Ist einfach nicht... So, genau, klar. Quatsch, braucht man nicht. Das waren Wir widerlegen bekannte Persönlichkeiten. Widerlegt, kant und wer auch immer gesagt hat, man soll wählen. Trottel der Demokratie erfunden. Wähli, das Demokratiemaskottchen. Oh, weißt du, wer die Demokratie erfunden hat? Die Res Publica? Griechen. I don't know. Keine Ahnung. Die haben Demokratie und Suflakis erfunden. Das ist auch eine gute Kommunikation. Das ist asiatische, Stereotype asiatische Musik. Das funktioniert nicht. Ja, vielen Dank, Stefan, für diese fantastische Folge. Ach ja, du musst ja eher los. Ihr ballert bitte noch weiter zu uns eure geilen App-Ideen.
Ich war noch nie so froh, dass du eher los musstest.
Heute ist uns nicht mehr die Themen ausgegangen, aber das wird uns nächste Woche ändern, denn wir haben eure App-Ideen.
Macht's gut, schöne Woche, bis zum nächsten Mal, wir heben ab und sagen Blububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububub